foxes cower at his name polar bears
follow his every order the name mr. big
strikes fear into the heart of many a
predator in Zootopia as well it should
mr. big after all is an arctic shrew and
shrews are fearsome predators turns out
some of the most formidable hunters in
nature come in surprising packages quick
think of a fearsome predator what comes
to mind crocodiles
Cobras Tigers you might not think to
flee at the sight of this northern short
tail true and that would be a mistake
these tiny guys can take down prey over
twice their size with a single bite
their secret venomous spit these shrews
are one of the only mammals on earth
with a toxic bite but even they can't
contend with our next hunter the
Mongoose they mostly dine on insects
small reptiles birds and rodents but
some species also go after cobras mambas
and other venomous snakes and sure it
takes guts to battle a full hooded Cobra
but there's more to this bravery than
meets the eye
these mongooses are resistant to
neurotoxins and snake venom normally the
toxins bind to muscle cell receptors
which block signals from the brain
causing paralysis but some mongooses
have specially shaped receptors that
fend off the toxins next up the giant
otter on average they're about as long
as a human man is tall and usually
prefer prey like catfish
and piranhas but on rare occasions
they've been known to go after prey at
least twice their length like anacondas
and croc like Caymans and they don't
even have secret weapons like toxic
saliva for help just their fellow otters
but believe it or not there's another
type of weasel who goes after even
bigger quarry the Wolverine Wolverines
are about the size of a Border Collie
and they've been known to hunt caribou
they like to ambush their prey and when
that doesn't work they have the gall to
try and steal prey from larger predators
like wolves and bears last but certainly
not least is perhaps the most
unsuspecting predator of them all meet
the epimers beetle right after birth
these hungry larvae are already on the
hunt frogs toads and salamanders are a
tasty meal but the newborns can't just
chase these large mules down instead
they lure their prey by tricking it into
attacking them then they swing around
sink their hooked
jaws into the flesh and latch on hmm
lunchtime whether you're dealing with a
beetle or a weasel the lessons clear
size isn't everything
which of these fearsome predators
surprised you the most let us know in
the comments and thanks for watching